- The underlying current
when people write about you.
- Yeah.
- Is who the (beep) is this guy?
- I mean, you get that, right?
- [Gary] Of course.
- Who the (beep) are you?
(ambient music)
- This is a word that is rarely
talked about in our space
that I wanna start building
more attention for.
Self-awareness.
I wanna deliver on
this message so much.
I would create a test or a drug
that allowed people
to become self-aware.
One potion inject,
not hustle, not smart.
Self-awareness.
I don't fear being self-aware.
I know I suck at a lot of stuff.
I think everybody
lies to themselves.
Some people are meant
to be B and C players.
And I'm pissed
that the narrative now
is that you need
to be a number one
and have your company.
Because a lot of
people are gonna lose
or leave money on the table,
because that's just the narrative.
'Cause I'm such a positive guy,
I struggle to think about
the things I'm bad at,
but self-awareness
requires understanding both
and then choosing which
path you wanna go through.
I'm a big fan of going
all in on your strengths.
And don't give a fuck
about what you suck at.
Self-awareness isn't only just
betting on your strengths,
it's accepting all
your shortcomings.
Let me tell you one thing.
What works for me does not
necessarily work for you.
I think being at peace with
yourself and your skill set
is such an important
part of this.
Too many people
try to be like me,
because it's sizzly
and it's sexy,
and people wanna be
charismatic and on stage.
So many of you do so many
things better than I do.
You can look at how people roll,
and it's great to admire
and things of that nature,
but it's so damn important
to stick to your DNA.
Try to get to a place where
you understand yourself
and understand what
your strengths are.
You've gotta find
your self-awareness.
All your shortcomings
are there for a reason.
They're there to also
allow you to be great.
Deep in your brain,
deep in your heart,
you actually accept
all those shortcomings,
is the second your life
goes on the offense.
I worry that people don't
tap into their strengths.
You have to audit
who you actually are,
because then you're not
gonna bullshit yourself.
You're gonna story-tell yourself,
you're gonna motivate yourself,
but you're not gonna
bullshit yourself.
And once you believe that,
either for yourself or
someone else told you,
go directly all chips,
all in to that.
And we've all got something,
and you just need to
accept what's yours
and go in on that.
Then you've got a
starting point to success.
And so self-awareness
at its finest
is accepting your shortcomings
and accentuating your strengths.
- Who the (beep) are you?
- I'm an entrepreneur.